[Music]
welcome everyone
meme review we're back baby we had a lot
of memes to go through so let's just Jim
so let's just jump into it hey remember
this this guy's face well he's back back
with more memes basically anything with
the first guy was probably like this guy
the first guy with insomnia was probably
that's good actually I like that alright
there's a lot of really clever
irritations of this yeah I said the word
first guy to ride a roller coaster would
have been like I mean yeah it's true
they use face have to make him smile
that's good that's really nice first guy
to ever get glasses mister be right it's
funny because it's scientifically
accurate and only really really smart
people would understand this meme dumb
people couldn't possibly understand this
me first guy to finally awake mister
peeny
now this is a meme of true intellectuals
oh you're awake I don't like I scare him
appropriate in my culture okay we don't
talk like this okay we talked like this
hello hello you're awake
that's what I would have sounded like
every was actually taking place in the
Nordics Viking region the first cell
that underwent mitosis was to be like
it's funny because it's scientifically
accurate laughing that's right you can't
laugh cuz you don't understand the man
first guy to find a wild Pokemon must
have been like all right now you went
too far wait what is this your ancestors
who were married and had three kids by
the time there were 20 watching you
struggle to walk past a girl yeah I
think they're really changed in time huh
but I have anime girlfriend now you
don't understand ancestors this is my
favorite one the fur
slime today was probably like it's funny
because it's also dipped in Minecraft
and I like that I will rate this meme a
solid peepee poo-poo very nice next meme
boys versus girls again the never-ending
battle X versus Y blue vs. yellow sweden
vs Sweden girls versus boys alright this
time the dispute is a between Photoshop
girls on Photoshop I can't get me this
is how girls talk by the way
it's not sexist this is scientifically
accurate I can make myself look skinnier
boys on Photoshop boys on Photoshop it's
funny because it's girl girls with
Photoshop I can't wait to make myself
look prettier boys win Photoshop you
can't stop us wham and sure of course we
have undying respect for you but you
will never beat us at our Photoshop game
boys with Photoshop it's the same punch
line over and over basically boys with
varnish is this offensive I can't tell
moving on boys this is the worst photo
of all time that I actually also really
enjoy it's so bad and so good at the
same time it's a perfect Alpha and Omega
it's beautiful well done boys man oh man
I'm gonna raid the boys Photoshop meme
Bing bong it gets a big bong Bing bong
bong bing bang bong what do you guys
think leave a comment down below I would
love to hear you guys thoughts I'd like
to see that as an interactive medium for
us to discuss ideas and not just for me
to get more comments a mixed mean please
a mixed next one please
oh yeah it's all coming together oh oh
oh oh yeah it's all coming together
that's pretty good I can't laugh at it
it's not funny
but I can go listen impressive I don't
like this kind of means I don't like
them they need to make me ha ha then
otherwise what's the point okay
what is this oh man
damn what are the odds whoa what are the
odds what are the odds how do they work
hello help damn it I haven't watched his
either I got to do so much research for
memes now I finally watched Jojo it was
epic and I was ready to come back and
enjoy the memes and now you've moved on
to something else what this this oh my
god oh yeah what is gonna happen it's
all that is he looking for chests meme
dealer yeah you gotta get coming
together
this person is having an epic minecraft
letsplay
Wow
well done you did it congratulations
it's all coming together oh yeah
it's all coming together hey look it's
the same mean just reskin epic this mean
gets to you don't like it that much
sorry gamers I gotta be honest if I'm
not honest then how can you trust my
thoughts on memes trust me it's way
easier to just take my opinions than
thinking for yourself it's a - okay it's
a - we agreed yes hello I realized a
threatening suite is like the least
threatening thing in the world
hello you do this yes hello thank you
thank you do this or else okay next man
Joker and Peter Parker dancing I love
this picture and I love it so much it's
a beautiful picture
I love how spider-man memes are finally
coming back and I'm just really excited
and it's a great photo that can
therefore be added a great caption sees
the same meal for the 1376 time my two
dogs only Edgar Maya's old now she
doesn't want the same food anymore and
there be like yeah uncooked lobsters
when the Titanic sank oh yeah I never
thought of that they must have been so
freakin happy or do they get trapped
inside maybe they are still living there
maybe there's like a whole lobster
family that's so wholesome I got a
thumbs up this video now the beasts are
freakin dying the media do you mean that
no one's reporting on it well there's a
reason minecraft what are you talking
about the memes are coming back we're
bringing them back baby hey when your
teacher kicks you your homey and your
random innocent dude out of class so
good I love this meme and this is how
the meme looks like when it's Pizza time
is there a meme that maybe I cuz I never
understand you 9 year olds you Zoomers
is there a meme that boomers will
understand and you guys won't understand
what did I enjoy as a child
nothing I like nothing next meme what I
enjoyed as a child with Star Wars wheels
on shopping cart be like another me I
like these means they're not they don't
have that much depth to them you know
they're gonna be gone super fast but
they're still fun like I can laugh at
them haha
I can go haha Wilson chopping kart be
like why did they do that why is there
always that one dumbass spinning one
whoever designed wheels and shopping
cards be like bruh okay this one is
animated that's epic I got a hit loop
there you go we'll set shopping car
white explain the science I can't laugh
at it it's not scientifically accurate
hell it's basically the the dentist's
meme all over again right when there's
one faulty tooth or though there's one
dentist that doesn't like it wheels on
shopping sir is there a clip of me
spinning no but there isn't my nipples
okay here you go gamers that will look
cool in post wheels own shopping cart be
like I'll try spinning that's a good
trick
moderately funny memes those are my
favorite those are the those are the
cherry on the top wheels on shopping
carts be like oh man now it's really
become the dentist's meme yes wheels on
shopping card at area 51 be like oh my I
like a meme very good I like the area
combination as well but this meme this
gets a let me taste it it's got a little
salt a little savory a little balls
it gets up okay that's what it gets if
anyone asks what you think of this meme
this is what you say life's meme guys
last memes and then we can move on and
then you're fully updated on the memes
that if anyone asked what you think of
you can be like blip blop it's this
Indian guy
running everyone I just told them sorry
we're out of chicken sandwiches it's
literally it's okay here's the original
one says two guys chillin and then
whatever happened no one knows but he
gets super angry why did they make this
with support I'm so confused
but it leads to the only thing important
here it doesn't matter okay
they leads to good memes and that's
really what we should all ask us ourself
about anything what's the purpose of
this if it isn't good memes then what's
the point
[Music]
haha I understand this because there's a
Joe Joe reference and I watched in there
I only watched season one 20 year old me
when the ice cream truck pulls up it's
funny cuz it's relatable I feel like
there has to be a tease there has to be
a pity pie versus there's a meme in
there just oh this guy chick-fil-a
sandwiches are better no
oh man see this is what I'm here for
oh hey Enderman yeah that's a good edit
that's very nice you are not the father
girl runs backstage cameraman
[Applause]
ohh-kay ah that was it for this week's
meme review hope you guys enjoyed smash
like if you did also what cool vest your
rain boots thank you it's Newt Suki I
wasn't wearing it correctly damn it its
new scheme market check it out right now
we have liftoff Suki doctor market very
nice we have ton the new stuff of course
don't forget represent calm such beauty
500 million club merch
alright gamers that's it for me for now
see you gamers next time a little tickle
oh if you thought the video was over oh
no no no we're playing last shelter
survival I get to command sexy ladies
okay I make a road so this is how mafia
works or I don't understand okay I built
the garage I did it can't just build
water okay fine
I built water then I click on water and
then I build water and I just patch a
guy what kind of shoes does ninja wear
sneakers
let me guess I'm gonna build the
residential area yes a house I couldn't
figure out how to fasten my seat belt
then it clicked
let me guess we're gonna build food yeah
I'll build food what do you say to a
slow tomato ketchup
uh me why is everyone hungry what this
is Africa good joke Felix
so for those who you plebs who don't
know this is a strategic video game
alright
it requires big brainpower but first you
gotta know how to play the game so
excuse me
I guess I'll transport and then I'll put
the things ok and saying see not anyone
can figure out how to do this try and
keep up whoa there's a chat hello um new
game hi guys
alright we need to build military let's
build a fighter camp where we build fire
camp here next to the food and I will
build a road and then we'll send a guy
for free time flies like an arrow fruit
flies like bananas fruit flies get it
okay
all right look at this my editor they
won't leave me alone I'm recording a
video you dumb we need to upgrade our
boss we need House level to ration level
2 ok ration Oh house go is there a best
month maybe maybe hey let me try a pun
never mind
now I built solar panel which can fly
like angel the bank keeps us paid in
cash but don't think that's how banks
works upgrade the goddamn tribe
thank you where's the pun dude you're
going offroad so what's outside are
there gonna be some bees later oh god
there's gonna be zombies later guys all
right we got ration truck level 2 this
is epic there's all maybe another camp
show Tim oh my god it's what's gonna
happen he's got a barrel alright that's
how you know they're enemies because I
hate barrels if you're new on this
channel you might not know there's I
freaking hate barrels nothing we can
build selling up [ __ ] we can't build son
I need to build a bank why can I not
build bank because my bays needs to be
level 3 but I can't level 3 in my bank
of
my bank is based level five not five not
six not seven all right
upgrading so far they're zombies there's
just a couple of zombies that's fine it
happens it happens I don't like it I do
not like it at all
kill the zombies how's our water doing
all right that's good keep going water I
feel like if people that know how to
play this game is watching me play this
a blind man walks into a bar and a table
and hits
I like the truck
I like the truck a lot I like a lot the
truck are you level three yet two
seconds one second zero second all right
now we can build a mother flipping bank
and we gonna make some Bank in the bank
all right Bank where is that money
perhaps banks yes keepers paid in cash
build it here crazy
well we truly live in a society oh my
god what the hell what is happening okay
sure so I guess we're gonna have a
pretty epic base eventually have we not
built this work work I like that that's
a reference isn't it I don't see why we
shouldn't build the shooting range I'm
poor how do I get money upgrade bank to
increase okay I've read the goddamn bank
thing so far pretty good Society people
are walking around having a good time
walking through each other that's fine
why am i so poor where's the farm we
need to build more farms I'm pretty sure
I didn't need to buy that but you know
that's how life goes dude how am I gonna
make that much money
this is like the paradox of life all
right I need to get a job but to get a
job
I need experience but I can't get a job
without experience I can't get money
without money and I'm not selling my
shooting range I need it I can train
Archer I have Archer now I'm trying shut
your mouth I don't care if you're super
sexy don't all right while we wait I
guess we can talk in the chat I will
block your ass
yeah I'll block life no one listening to
me oh I did it
the house is upgraded this changes
everything now it's like the same but a
three on a which means of course of
course is the moment you've all waited
for now I can finally upgrade god damnit
what am I missing
you know what screw it I'll spend
diamonds I don't care I don't care just
don't tell my mom all right I'm not
supposed to use her credit cards why is
the one talking to me hello help okay so
now we upgrade the house and we upgrade
a bank all right that means we can
upgrade base now we need a ration truck
whatever my congratulations to for
defeating level four why is no one
congratulating me
I missed the truck guy he was making
jokes and stuff all right so I was
supposed to be like a rush to was that
it ain't no ration truck god damn I'm
low on food these greedy bastards they
just want more and more I can't do it I
can't do it I'm not a good society
person god damn it
there's 600 people living in our society
that's pretty epic they all live in this
one house though it's not the best but
you know oh dude I had all these rewards
I'm ray
are you kidding me how about your heart
is that me that's me okay all right sure
there we go over 600 people's they're
just nuts they're just absolutely going
bananas banana flies okay must restore
power okay that's fine that's fine so
now we will construct a wind turbine in
the middle of the night because people
are relying on fire send the guy that
makes the jokes time flies like arrows
fruits like banana just bill the house
Larry okay no one asked you some bees
are marching that's fine
it happens all right we need to build a
power plane I've been wanting to that's
such a tiny power plant are you kidding
me when Batman escapes church it's
Christian yeah I like that one no time
for jokes were under attack all right so
where does the zombies come from they
said Southwest
help don't care don't care attack him I
meant a new word plagiarism ha ha ha yes
ok upgrade goddammit alright you already
said that joke you dummy I'm thinking
I'm doing pretty good I don't have a lot
of energy let's probably get some
electricity some solar panels
Switzerland is just oh alright but the
flag is a big plus ha ha ha all right
where's my girl coming I need to check
how far away she okay very epic yes send
the jokester I like how he sent himself
to himself absolute mad light got Tim I
don't have any power
hey my troops are back my boys hey oh
god that doesn't look good
that's fine we have fence we build the
wall guys okay there's a lot more of
them yep all right well this is the kind
of game where you keeps playing while
you're not playing which is very nice I
like those kind of games if you're
interested in last shelter survival
check out link in the description and
add me as a friend there and we can play
to get there yay
[Music]
you